never get to drink together i don't know
and i do have frozen breast milk i can
drink oh [ __ ] dope animals oh i
thought what
oh we were gonna make a pina colada yeah
i thought we were gonna
i meant i can drink yours and you're
gonna drink
i started like having a pancake and then
i was like i went into this acceptance
mode where i was like pictured
worst-case scenarios like i pictured
like the plane exploding and like
shrapnel going through my body and then
i was like my final destination yeah i
was like i accept yeah
what am i gonna do i'm
yeah i'm like i don't want to be in a
[ __ ] hospital where like my half of
my shit's all [ __ ] up yeah like i
definitely want to be like insta-death
if
and you want me to [ __ ] be maimed and
survive [ __ ] that take me
[Music]
hello welcome back to big moon and we're
all here four of us in a different state
texas y'all we're in texas this is the
podcast of the traveling pants before we
get into it can we can we talk about why
we're holding our mics like this oh yeah
people like what the [ __ ] yeah like we
don't have mike stanley like yeah eat
ice cream cones
yeah we can't touch the edge here we
can't touch the corner sorry if there's
noise normally we have mic stance but we
are right here at a convention we're in
a hotel room because we're going to a
convention here in austin texas that is
why that is what brought us together
today not our friendship and not our
friendship at all as we have pointed out
in previous episodes we're not friends
anymore if you don't talk on the phone
three times a week you're not friends
yeah that's how many times and if you
don't do that your face once every two
weeks so anyway we're doing our
traveling podcast
and we didn't bring the mic stands
they're too big we used to hold our
microphones but there were different
types of microphones that could have
been held and these microphones are
meant to be on stands so any little
movement that is touching this chord or
this mic
you will hear sounds in case you want
that episode
we are just gonna remain very still
we're gonna we're gonna like we can only
hold like a certain spot who who's
nicki's like it's like a [ __ ] ring yeah
your finger's gonna clock right at the
base like this you put it up here it's
gonna get lost yeah
[Laughter]
in the last two years or no two in the
last two years a [ __ ] or a [ __ ] ring
oh you had idiot bones
wait did you see where you're in the
zero [ __ ] rings i didn't actually even
see it i didn't actually see it i
haven't seen a [ __ ] ring ever i'm i've
never used a [ __ ] ring yeah i mean
neither oh okay so it's not that how do
you know what one is why'd you tell us
to protect
about them and i know how they operate
what am i supposed to do because i get
curious and i google things i think uh
well the only way i've seen one actually
my ex used to be a bartender at a gay
club and so like the dancers that were
there would use the [ __ ] rings because
they would have their little their
little bikini bottoms on and so they
would put their dick in their balls in
this like [ __ ] ring and it would kind of
like fluff it up
it would make their well some of them do
oh it has to be straight but i think it
i think it's supposed to it serves
multiple purposes like pushes all the
blood and stuff to the yeah maybe it
could help keep it harder or maybe it
could also be like uh like it could
hit again yeah like that's what i heard
it's more like it makes the right spot
you know how girth kind of matters more
than length because like the width hits
the walls in the correct way like we're
hitting that spot over and over i think
i thought that's what it was like ribbed
condoms you know no i don't think a [ __ ]
ring makes the dick whiter no no not
whiter no the the ring around it like
you can feel it in the the lady
two people who have never experienced a
god
i don't know the only time i've ever
seen it in practice was like gay dancers
like wrapping their [ __ ] and then so it
just makes the makes their bulge bigger
i didn't learn what a fluffer was until
like two years ago in porn because i
thought a fluffer i swear to god i
thought it was just someone that comes
over and brushes their bush so that's
better that's so funny it's kind of like
me when i was in middle school and
people would be like well have you ever
given a [ __ ] i'm like don't you just
like blow on it
i thought a blow drop was a hair dryer
thing for so long i was like well yeah
yeah i do blow jaws after the shower
everything
i don't like the sound
every time i should really
you know this is like the episode of
south park when carmen's like you never
finger bang a girl bang bang
exactly
existed that's like not even a part of
our that's not our generation japan
okay yeah
so then later on people like no gina
pulled me aside like the gina no no no
oh by the way if you guys can hear
lucas crying right next door oh i can
hear him yeah i'm like we can probably
hear you are your nipples they left him
alone over there there's no one watching
him it is here's you he's just sitting
on the bed by himself there's no one
over there terrible parents
um i also thought a rim job had to do
with basketball a rim job
i think i just always knew what all
these nasty things were and i don't know
how i never thought anything was what it
wasn't i just was like oh that's what
that is you're just gifted with that i
just want you to know what i'm saying
all right like when i heard it like it
was explained to me exactly what it was
oh so you never had to guess what it was
no oh how do you cheated [ __ ] was so
like it took me so long a hotel room
light looks like a butthole like a
butthole it does
yeah very open stretched out
so i uh i was on tiktok last week and i
came across this [ __ ] video that made
me scream internally and vomit
uh i didn't know that during birth i
only i i thought you ripped backwards i
didn't know you can rip your [ __ ] oh
wait wait wait wait
i thought you were the front towards the
back too
wait how do you rip your [ __ ]
not your clip but like towards the face
oh my god you focus
i can't focus my baby's crying babies
crying in the next room that's okay if
you want to go hold the baby go ahead
and throw up real quick yeah what are
you really picking about about the [ __ ]
ribbon yeah oh don't throw up for real
my eyes stop it but yeah i didn't know
like ripped forward i thought i only
ripped backwards
about those but it is possible i guess
low set [ __ ] maybe
[Music]
i think mine set kind of high a low set
vagina
low set clip problems so let's measure
our vagina openings to our buttholes
see how far that is
not endangered
my vagina my butthole is so far away my
diarrhea never touched my vagina oh my
god i am of the upper echelon
oh you low class glitch
sorry
no i knew i don't know if i ever told
you guys but i knew some girl that she
ripped all the way to the to her anus
and like her every time she pooped for
like
months
and months like i think her kid was like
almost a year old and she still couldn't
they didn't sell that [ __ ] oh so it just
hurt it just always i thought you were
gonna say it like went up into the
vagina and she kept getting utis i feel
like that would happen too because like
fecal matter getting up there is what
like ripped yeah because e coli is like
what are you talking about
screaming i know my baby's screaming we
went to free ball this conversation and
this is what you get that's what you get
when we're not you know when we're not
told what to do this [ __ ] happens
women should always be told what to do
we're in texas yeah isn't it
what it's actually in texas
i do not claim this
we're actually in austin there's a lot
of blue haired people here so
yeah that's my dress represents my hair
right now we're in asylum right now
we're at a gaming convention so for in
within like the next five block vicinity
everyone's blue yeah everything yeah
yeah just a lot of people watching
museum we're safe yeah we're safe we're
safe here
never leave downtown austin
literally has a neon sign that says
hashtag selfie museum wow i was like
we're in l.a yeah this is honestly
austin is starting to feel a lot like la
it's almost like i never left
even though i wanted to
[Music]
so um here's what i'm going to do you
guys talk i'm going to order liquor so
you left me
you left because you wanted to jess hon
you left a friend group a friend group
that was all in the same city didn't
exist but it could have hung out once
we were through a pandemic you know you
do you didn't give after you have a
chance because it was in the middle of a
pandemic no i was in a pandemic for a
while before i left yeah exactly
pandemic
so we came to her this time
it was a never-ending pandemic
but yeah no i mean i'm a full-fledged
adult now with like real job
and that's the way i like it no i'm
going to throw it up
right
wait no make sure you
[ __ ] adult with the job too
but your job doesn't happen you don't
have a real job you just have a place
where you have to go i'm awake so early
honestly the thought of going into an
office with fluorescent lighting from
nine to five is
my hell i think that when i was a kid
that was my dream what yeah i wanted to
know you don't want to work out i wanted
to live the corporate life so bad i want
to have my own desk my own cubicle and
decorate it because my mom had a cubicle
yeah and
i would go visit her like bring your kid
to work day whatever and she had like
her own little mini water water gallant
thing that's cute and i don't know she
just like made it so cute where i'm like
i can't wait to get an office job well
like when you grew up in tijuana of
course that's your dream job i guess
you're going to grow up in it she's like
either that or responds you know like
that yeah selling responders on the side
of the road so i get it
yeah but no and then i always wanted a
locker too because i my high school
didn't have a locker so i wanted to
decorate my locker high school yeah the
[ __ ] no i'm with you i i remember going
to my mom's office and i i thought like
oh when you're an adult you get a
computer because computers like back in
the 90s like not everyone had a computer
like that was like
not in everyone's house like it wasn't
in anyone's house until like 1995. and
if it wasn't your house it had its own
room yeah a computer room computer
kids weren't really allowed to go in
there
it was like really special to have a
computer i didn't have this existence i
don't know okay so yeah i didn't have it
in my house i just knew from the we had
a computer but we didn't have a computer
room oh
we gotta have a computer late like i
mean later you're a little bit younger
than me but i was like 11 or 12. you're
three years younger than two years
younger than me i'm thirty-five i know
okay they're three years younger never
mind
why are you getting suspended she's
literally
you're like three years younger than me
i just know i'm the oldest that's all i
know
anyway i was like 12 before we got a
computer and so yeah it was it was like
a big deal and so i thought that like
holy [ __ ] when you're an adult you get
to go to a job and you have a computer
and that's [ __ ] sick and so it's a
big deal definitely like romanticized
corporate america yeah
once we got a computer in our house like
and then i went to work for my mom when
i was 14 i was like filing papers i
could not handle that lighting like so
i'm a light a white person i'm very
sensory overload offices are different
now you know that right it's not 1980
i never want to go back to fighting
they're like they're like different
they're like fun now you know dude my
office is fun are studios starting to
open up to public like live audience so
yeah that's cool
hell yeah you're gonna come watch the
[ __ ] fiasco please invite me i want
to go yeah it's super fun um and it's in
burbank it's so close to you well um
i live in she doesn't live there anymore
i live here i used to live in burbank
too it would have been real close to me
it is actually the two out of state
people it is closer to me than it is i
totally forgot for a second holy [ __ ]
that's weird you know it's just weird
about the old house and now i'm sad i
know sometimes i think about that house
and it's like it's weird it feels like
i've just been on a permanent vacation
yeah yeah like none of it's real yeah i
do feel like my house feels like a
resort somehow we all left weird yeah
life splintered off and like i thought
you were kidding when you said it really
oh that's funny she wasn't moving i
totally forgot does your probiotic
contain clinically studied strains okay
we'll meet one that does rituals
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials i love ritual vitamins so as you
know i have been taking ritual vitamins
since i don't know 2017 or 18. i can't
remember i started with the women's and
then i moved on to the prenatal in
2019 and i have just been loving taking
ritual vitamins it's super easy it comes
to my door it has everything that i need
in a vitamin i definitely feel a
difference in overall health on top of
that my nutritionist had been telling me
to take a probiotic and wouldn't you
know ritual has the best one for me it's
more than a probiotic it's three in one
with clinically studied prebiotics
probiotics and a postbiotic to support a
balanced gut microbiome i cannot stress
the importance of gut health did you
know that your gut is like a second
brain it like really is connected to
your emotions and overall well-being it
affects decision making and judgment
it's pretty nuts i didn't know until i
got sibo and had to clear all that stuff
up i thought i was just living a normal
life but uh no i was living a terrible
life before i fixed my gut health and
probiotics probiotics and postbiotics
have everything to do
with supporting a balanced gut
one daily capsule for simple streamlined
gut support is all you need and you get
it in this single nested minty capsule
it smells so good it's a delayed release
capsule designed to help reach the colon
not the stomach which is an ideal place
for probiotics to survive and grow and
there's no refrigeration needed it's
designed with moisture controlled bottle
technology to protect the probiotic
strains symbiotic plus and ritual are
here to celebrate not hide your insides
there's no more shame in your gut game
that's why ritual is offering our
listeners 10 off your first three months
visit ritual.com big mood to start
ritual or add symbiotic plus to your
subscription today it's too nice out to
be too damn high just because we've aged
out of summer break doesn't mean we
don't need to chill out ditch the
munchies paranoia and potency of today's
weed with dead grass dead grass's legal
organic hemp that relaxes your body
mellows your mind dead grass cbd
products are made with 100 organic hemp
that's easy to dose and the effects come
on smooth they offer a variety of
products from their token smokable
pre-rolled joints as well as hemp flour
and variety of cbd tincture drops enjoy
the effects of cbd while keeping a clear
head all dad grass products are
federally legal for ages 18 and over and
it ships right to your door anywhere in
the us go to dadgrass.com
big mood to check out their products
whether you're looking for a new buzz or
a chill way to enjoy an old favorite dad
grass will leave you in a euphoric mood
right now dadgrass is offering our
listeners 20 off your first order when
you go to dadgrass.com big mood go to
dadgrass.com big mood for 20 off your
first order again that's dadgrass.com
big mood i haven't been to la since the
beginning of february when we did a
shoot at your place um
and so now it's july i don't know when
this is coming out but
um i wanted to go back because i need a
haircut my haircut lady is i mean i've
never gone to a different person in 13
years so oh really no like i said i
don't want bougie i mean that's gonna
happen if something happens to her i
don't know i literally will never cut my
hair again
she's like a little she you know she has
a little bit of the tissums yeah yeah
yeah
the same person i trust very few people
yeah um so yeah like i wanna go next
time steve does jk i was gonna go to la
and just like spend a few days or
whatever so
hopefully maybe you're doing your show
and you have a live audience wednesdays
that would be sick okay yeah you have to
go early because he goes like thursday
or something right you have to he leaves
on wednesdays because to film on
thursday you can you have to leave on a
tuesday
maybe i'll leave on tuesday get my
haircut for this live audience so
because they show the audience
you have to get her in the shop
yeah i know i should have yeah they
needed to tell them
[Applause]
[Laughter]
nick has been on youtube forever
together yeah yeah
never heard of you who are you still
talking to me oh there was this washed
up youtube star that i used to watch
just kidding i kid love cats so much
it's me i really do love casting so much
he's amazing he's amazing i'm so glad
you guys are on a show together it's
like my two worlds like met and you guys
are so funny our ongoing joke is that
he's like always constantly hitting on
people or horny and i'm the one who just
thinks he's disgusting
just the grossest thing ever and he
plays it so well i love loving him
that's awesome
how is he with his crows
oh yeah i want to know how that's going
i don't know how that's going lately i
think he's been doing that for like a
year he was in a fight with squirrels
for a while what the crows probably had
his back though because they're they're
loyal
loyal ass [ __ ] we sent him to the uh
renaissance fair and it was a [ __ ]
fiasco it was amazing we had him throw
a
javelin or something that man has very
small bird arms and it was hilarious
yeah i really want you guys to come to
the show yeah i think you guys have such
a great time did we talk about the crows
on the podcast episode
gina is obsessed with the truth
i was obsessed with birds and you guys
called it autism yeah and
then that's why we thought maybe and
then we had both talked about that we
have both seen the same thing about it
it was on the episode
okay i just wanted to make sure that
that was on the episode she bought an
entire bag to feed birds so
they disappeared when i watched the new
season of umbrella academy and there's
that one oh [ __ ]
i'm like see
gina and i's [ __ ] dream like
super powerful i just want crow friends
man that'd be dope and just steal things
for me yeah
and well sometimes they bring you dead
rats but i'm fine with that miller would
love that yeah there you go a present
for your cat that's nice
but they only like recognize if you
accept it if you reject their gift then
they're like how do you accept that
please make sure that you like you take
it like so they leave it and you take it
um but if you
if you leave it like you don't take it
they're like oh they shouldn't like that
oh
you know my gift language or my my love
language is gifts yeah yeah this would
be [ __ ] great you're gonna have so
many crow lovers yeah i'm just building
a whole pro house right now dude it's
gonna be dope i'll come
why is my hanging out my [ __ ] house
again they like me too gina
she's got cash she got crows we're best
friends like gina and i like have so
many weird similarities oh yeah are you
all sexual talks we're so great oh yeah
i know i'm getting choked even though
i'm like yep
whenever we all hang out we shoot for a
little bit it's always me and nikki that
kind of like at the end of the day we're
like hey we're going to sit over here
and be quiet yeah but we're still
involved yeah we don't want to like we
want to be like i don't want to like i
have fomo yeah i'm going to go sit in a
room by myself from afar yeah we like to
see each other people enjoying
themselves and you know what's also
funny is that gina and i are the most
on-camera performer people and you guys
aren't but you guys like socializing and
we like feel like we need to recharge
when we're not
like on yeah like we just can't be on 24
7. it is so funny yeah and then if it's
like if i can't contribute like all of
my energy to the conversation because
i'm drained from just doing podcasts for
four hours then i'm not gonna be a
pleasant person anyway so i'd rather
just watch you guys enjoy yourself yeah
and smile i just filmed um 12 hour days
two 12 hour days back to back this past
week
and i'm
i'm dead i am so dead i like every day
after work i go into my car and i just
sit there like oh
just like in silence in the parking lot
and you love it right i love your job
you love what you do it's just like it
just takes your like it's like this was
what i was meant to do and i gave my
energy to this thing and now i need to
recharge oh speaking of which so uh our
new show arena uh we have like
celebrities and athletes and stuff come
in we had nfl players this past week so
i'm trying to find you a boyfriend oh
not me at all yeah nfl players you could
get steve
i wouldn't date anyone famous
yeah that would be kind of oh
i said i would never date a youtuber and
then now i've been married for like
forever i've never seen them eternity
multiple times
over and over
are you looking for for yourself a man
uh no michael b jordan
what happened oh he's single
now yes he is yes michael jordan is
very single and i told you that he was
just like getting him on that roster
right dana was just playing hard to get
freddie prince
tell him that he needs to get michael b
jordan to come on i should yeah and then
have him and then tell him that he needs
eminem to be on there yeah and then
there's no there's no there's no room
there's no room for that yeah you know i
met recently i met um trying to keep you
and steve married
that's true thank you you're a bit
serious it's not that serious that's
fine
it's her pass
we had a we had
first we had game night at freddie
prince's house last week and i met um
seth green
like the nicest hello yeah he and his
wife his wife is really nice too and we
just sometimes sit there i'm like huh
you're literally
like our 90s kids dream yeah it was seth
green freddy prince jr and then freddy's
married to sarah michelle gellar yeah
you know they're still married yeah but
they're still married
they have two kids yeah and i'm sitting
here i'm like wow this is like that's
weird
that would weird me out honestly yeah
that's so strange yeah it's like in a
time capsule yeah that's cool yeah it's
it's strange but it's fun yeah yeah yeah
just a bunch of nerds that play dean i
love it
who knew that they would be so nerdy
right
yeah freddie prince and sarah michelle
gilbert i mean sarah michelle is buffy i
mean you got to be around a bunch of
comic nerds she doesn't play a long time
by the time we get there she puts the
kids to sleep but he like him seth and
them they're like massive nerds i could
see seth green being a massive guy huge
freddie prince jr played the heartthrob
in all the movies so like it's harder
for me to wrap my head around him than
like seth green who was always playing
the nerds yeah
or like the like guy was trying to be
cool but he was like clearly like a
loser yeah
i was i was i saw this video have you
guys seen that diary of a wimpy kid
i haven't seen this movie
apparently there's a movie they made
about it and uh the the main actor the
kid went nuts and he got arrested
because he shot his mom in the back of
her head what yeah dude i just saw it
like
his mom was playing piano he shot her in
the back of the head and then he
gathered all of his [ __ ] guns and
whatever and was gonna he routed a a a a
way to justin trudeau in canada and
wanted to go kill him but it took too
long so he wanted to go to his
university instead and kill them but
then something happened he decided not
to and he just turned out
how old he got his mom yeah he only
killed his mom because he didn't want
her to see what he was about to do oh my
god yeah he's like this kid actor that
went nuts it's like dude what the hell
what's his name i don't remember
how old he's like a team he's older now
he's an adult now okay yeah whoa yeah
damn that crazy
i also saw something about some rapper
that um he
got caught
putting a hit on his mom or something oh
oh i said my favorite story is this
woman who her husband put a hit on her
and he she killed the hitman instead
like she strangled the [ __ ] out of him
and she said tell me who sent you and
i'll let you live and he wouldn't tell
her so he [ __ ] killed her or she
killed him yeah and then she find out um
i don't know how she found out but then
the husband like
imagine being that husband and finding
out that your wife killed hate men you
sent oh my god
[ __ ] his pants and then she found out
who it was right he's doing this you're
still alive right why are your hands all
[ __ ]
out
they found like that he got arrested
that's good i've been doing a lot of
[ __ ] [ __ ] lately on tick-tock
i've been reading or listening to a lot
of those
they're really interesting there's that
whole meme that like women are obsessed
with true crime even though we're
usually the victims of it yeah and it's
true like i don't know why that's a
thing like maybe because we're so
interested in the ways that
people are so scared that we can like
protect ourselves you know so we can
survive yeah survival thing that makes
sense but i don't know or maybe like i
don't know i like mysteries and like
solving them but
i've been watching those uh i'm not
super into true crime but i've been
watching this one youtube channel that
shows um all of the interviews of the
what is it called like the
interrogations oh yeah and they'll be
like this is the body language so this
is like the the most
what's the word i'm thinking of um
psychopathic like 15 year old you'll
ever [ __ ] see or whatever and then
they just it'll be like the whole
hour-long interrogation interrogation
with like commentary and i'm like i
think i'm more interested in that
because yeah i'm not really interested
in the story of a man murdering a
[ __ ] woman but i'm like just seeing
them talk about it afterwards i'm like
oh that's [ __ ] crazy yeah are they
like confessing are they trying to yeah
like or some some are confessing just
straight up because they enjoy it
they're narcissists and they love it and
like they're like proud of what they did
and then some are lying obviously but
yeah that channel was pretty interesting
excuse me women do love true crime stuff
it's so interesting mm-hmm so odd i
don't know if i would say describe it as
odd but it is like
captivating maybe because it's like we
can't fathom it i don't know i don't
really know what interests me about it
like i guess the human condition of like
psychological [ __ ] like how what drives
people to do that i'm very interested in
like what drives people to do things
as in acting that's what she misses you
i'm like what is gina doing with my hand
right now she misses you like this is
how you hold this this is how we show
love jesus you just poo poo on it how
are you holding hands
you're hard to love jess this is so cool
this is how quiet people hold hands yeah
what do you do is this a broken finger
one this one oh gross
contagious
bones
i couldn't even tell which one it was
[Laughter]
kill the weak bone germs i know so how
was it wait did you guys drive here it
flew here flew yes oh yeah it was luca's
first flight how was that oh yeah i had
my first panic attack
my very first [ __ ] panic attack in my
life on a plane so when we were talking
to
i know i talked to jess about it
yesterday and i'm like i so understand
you now and i never i couldn't fathom it
before like how can someone be afraid of
flying like yeah sure it's dangerous
whatever but like really
no i [ __ ] felt it so when we took off
i think we had like a student pilot or
something because this pilot was [ __ ]
up so we as we were taking off we had to
do like this turn and like the turn was
so sharp that we felt in such intense
g-force that both me and casey casey
said it too that he felt his whole brain
like [ __ ] scramble and like the
g-force was so intense i was holding
luca at my chest and i was literally
stomping on the floor because it was too
much like i couldn't [ __ ] wait
everything was like forced i'm done
when you go too fast and or up and down
whatever in your stomach
like the roller coaster type of thing
yeah like that so it was so intense
that
i couldn't even see straight it was like
so blurry and i was like i hate that
you're not supposed to take turns like
that with a password i couldn't even
like i felt like my chest was like
tightening yeah during that the g-forces
for that kind of force yeah and then i
was like maybe i'm [ __ ] tripping
because no one in this plane is saying
they were all like
yeah everyone's like oh my god because
then i looked over to him he goes yeah
like it's a lot and then after it
stopped
i
i i was like i lost i was
hyperventilating even me just retelling
it right now like i'm feeling it again
scary i could feel it i started
hyperventilating when i was like
oh my god and i was like trying to hold
luca and then casey was like you want me
to take luca i'm like no no i feel
better with him in my arms like i feel
like i need to protect him and i just
started panicking where i'm like oh my
god like my whole brain was spinning and
i couldn't breathe and i was actually
holding back the tears i was about to
start crying where i'm like what the
[ __ ] i've grown up i've been happier
just on a plane after some turbulence
like we're gonna [ __ ] die and people
are like no we're not i'm like you don't
know that
you can't promise me that you don't know
you're not there you can't see anything
yeah and like for the rest of the flight
i was like okay i just calmed
everything's okay like i kept talking to
myself like you're okay luca's safe
casey's okay everyone's fine just
breathe it's all right you'll get
through this and then as we were getting
ready to descend i was also freaking out
too because or like really anxious about
making sure that luca was sucking on
something for the pressure changes
because then like it will
stabilize his ear pressure so so i
started feeding him right before it take
off because they were like all right
we're cleared for for takeoff and i was
like okay cool i latch him on and then
we just stay there for 15 minutes and
then he finishes eating and then that's
when we start leaving so i'm like
everything was just going wrong so like
just stuck on the pacifier luckily he
was okay he was a little fussy for like
a little bit and then when we started
landing
that's when i'm like okay time to feed
again pacifier all that and then i
started getting like that panic feeling
again
because there was like some turbulence
and then i was just like please pilot
don't do that again don't do it again
like don't do the g4 [ __ ] and then um
like i ended up
asking casey i'm like
how far away are we from the ground
because i had the windows the shades
closed because it was really bright so i
was asking him to look over across the
aisle and then
i'm like freaking out i guess not
visually because he couldn't tell
because then casey's like oh no we're
still really far away from the show
oh [ __ ] and i felt like my whole like
stomach dropped when he said that and
i'm like over here holding looking like
it's okay calm down it's all right we're
gonna be you say you're gonna land like
sooner or later yeah
because i felt like i was already like
coping for such a long time yeah and
then i'm like how far away we were
trapped yeah he was like we're still
really far yeah i was like
oh no he's like we're still really high
up and i'm like holy [ __ ] and then like
some time passes by and it felt like an
eternity for me and i'm like are we
still really far and then he was like oh
yeah still and i told casey i'm like
okay that's really not helping him
what's he what's he supposed to say like
i don't know he could lie to me like
it's okay like we're almost there like
something but i guess he couldn't see
that i was panicking maybe
because i would think you'd be scared of
like the plane landing while you're
feeding like like
like you got time before we're landing
if i'm casey but that's just
yeah this is like no but then the funny
thing is after i said that
i guess because maybe you were anxious
too i don't know but after i said that i
was like okay i'm just trying to focus
on like making sure luca's sucking on
the pacifier and like just let me just
cope and then we hear the wheels like
you know the the noise the wheels coming
out
and then i said nothing but then casey
goes
so the wheels just came out but we're
still still really high up and i'm like
remember i said that's not helpful
like please stop telling me how high up
we are like please
and then i was just like okay the wheels
are coming down like all right we're
getting close and then i just that was
just the first horrible flight
experience in my life and then casey was
saying like maybe you felt really
vulnerable because it's your first time
flying with a baby and like you know you
want to protect him like maybe you were
just feeling
just really in a scary position i guess
and i'm like i think that's what it was
i didn't realize i had a panic attack
until we were in the car and i was
retelling the story to his parents and
i'm like oh my god i think that that was
a panic attack i couldn't couldn't
breathe i was trying to stop tears from
coming like i was i was i felt like i
wanted to stop like just [ __ ] whale
and cry and i was just like keep it
together keep it together i've never
felt that i've only had one panic attack
it was last year and i didn't know what
the hell it was really yeah i i was
laying in bed in the middle like i
remember the story because yeah
x
uh situation no it was uh no it was so i
was laying in bed uh my sister was
sleeping next to me because she was
coming to visit you know like that that
that that one moment when you're about
to fall asleep and it's so soft and
because she like yeah that really sweet
spot uh my roommate made a loud noise
and shook me awake and i was like oh
[ __ ] and then i tried to go back to
sleep um but i couldn't i was like weird
i can't breathe so i'm gonna lay in my
back and see what happens and then i
laid there on my back and i was like
wait a minute my breathing is getting a
lot more shallow what's happening and
then my vision started getting blurry my
brain started getting foggy my
extremities started tingling and going
numb afterwards and cold
and i yeah something was going on there
and then that's not typical no no oh
[ __ ] and then like i remember thinking
um i need help but i don't want to wake
up my sister because i don't want to
scare her
and then i and then i remember thinking
oh [ __ ] i think i'm dying
all right well i guess this is how i die
and it was so peaceful i was like okay
well this is yeah that's not really how
panic attack is what the [ __ ] happened
to me then you probably almost died i
don't know maybe you didn't have enough
vitamins i don't know did you drink any
water you stood up too fast did you have
a food maybe your heart didn't have a
food your heart might have stopped i
don't know it was so weird and then um
like everything started closing in and
then all of a sudden like i snapped out
of it i ran to the bathroom and i
vomited and then i went back to bed and
i was fine that was maybe you had a
stroke yeah that's weird huh
weird i don't know like a mini stroke or
something yeah i don't know that's not
normal and you don't get [ __ ] calm
during a panic attack no and you don't
think i don't want to wake somebody like
you're like
i can't survive i'm trying to like i'm
trying to cling to life
panic attack feels like it did like i
was gonna die this would be great
interesting but it was freaking out i
was gonna say that like so i had a panic
i get panic attacks all the [ __ ] time
yeah but i'm sweaty too i get them like
everywhere drenched sometimes i don't
know if i'm conscious enough to realize
if my hands are sweating like mostly i'm
hyperventilating and like
like tears are falling out of my face
and like i
just like feel like i can't breathe um
but and like but oh something in my head
sometimes like i feel like just like a a
strong pressure like right here like a
migraine no not like a migraine um but
like like almost like a wave of panic
starts here and then
and then flows and i start crying and
then like then it goes here and i'm
hyperventilating and like it goes like a
wave through me and it starts here and
usually i can tell when it's coming on
because i feel it like starting right
here where like everything starts going
like blurry like it starts right here
and like the room feels like it's
closing and on me that's definitely what
it felt like yeah yeah that was a panic
attack for sure but so i started to get
one because i i used to get them during
turbulence but then i would like look at
i'd have to like look at the flight
attendants and like see how calm they
are and like just try to channel their
calmness from that for me
it doesn't not saying it's perfect it's
not gonna work for everyone it doesn't
work every time but this time um
weirdly like when we were taking off the
plane started going like this this was
on the flight here um the plane was
going like this and i'm like oh my god
most crashes are during takeoff and
landing like i know but the statistics
crashes and so it started like going
like this i know and i'm like
i started like having a pancake and then
i was i went into this acceptance mode
where i was like pictured worst case
scenarios like i pictured like the plane
exploding and like shrapnel going
through my body and then i was like my
final destination yeah i was like i
accept
yeah i accept yeah i have nothing i
don't know yeah
what am i gonna do i'm good i'm gonna
die
yeah i don't mind the diet i don't mind
the dying part i just don't to live
after being like named
yeah i'm like i don't want to be in a
[ __ ] hospital where like my half of
my shit's all [ __ ] up yeah like i
definitely want to be like insta death
if it happens that's what i think i'm
more afraid of is like getting [ __ ] up
and like not dying yeah that's why i'm
scared of an apocalypse i'm like that's
why i want to just kill me just tell me
i don't want to be like halfway [ __ ]
up yeah see lots of things like i'm so
vain
that like even if my eyebrows aren't
even that day i want to [ __ ] die oh
my god
like your body has to be pristine too
when you die i got a pimple the other
day and almost ended it all day guys and
you want me to [ __ ] be maimed and
survive [ __ ] that take me out stupid
probably think songs about you too i do
i do
don't you yes i do
so here we're gonna make a pact here
if gina gets maimed
she gets one is
yeah this is my living will if i get
made if i lose anybody well actually now
i would look sick with bionic legs okay
if i ever get like i think the
extremities are okay to lose
you're fine the face no somebody could
do the half two-faced thing like
a haste tattoo or some [ __ ] maybe
if i'm doing it
don't worry i need my i need my face
or if i become like i can't even move
anymore take me out yeah that one's hard
you know what you guys were talking
about like you being afraid of dying i
actually it made me remember a thought i
had on the airplane when everything was
happening and i was panicking
i was the thought of like the p the
plane crashing did cross my mind but i
was just focused on holding luca that
i'm like okay my body will protect him
like i was just thinking like i don't
care if i die that was probably the only
time you were fearing death was because
you had literally
so you've never had a panic attack
before because you're like i don't give
a [ __ ] if we die but now you're like oh
but he can't die yeah
yeah cause the first i think i care
about my life maybe that's what about
why i constantly have i mean i just care
about my life too if i'm thinking about
my kids like that doesn't make sense why
i'm not afraid of my own death i don't
know i gotta analyze that but
i
it made me realize too like i had never
flown with the baby because with isaac
his first flight was when he was three
oh
and it's probably a little easier it was
way easier he was loving it he had his
own seat he was like you
did learn
he cried a little bit he was a little
fussy but
like overall he was a really good baby
he actually slept for so it was a two
and a half hour flight and he slept for
like 45 minutes of it at one point
and he was fine for the rest of it oh
good that's good yeah he cried like he
was fussy for just a tiny bit yeah not
that bad it's pretty typical take action
today for a healthier tomorrow with
everly well their at-home lab tests and
vitamins and supplements can help you
get the knowledge and support you need
so you can become a healthier you everly
well is digital health care designed for
you all at an affordable and transparent
price with over 30 at-home lab tests
you'll be able to choose the test that
makes the most sense for you to get the
answers you need like the women's health
test or food sensitivity test which is
actually a test that i took i found it
so interesting to discover that my
highest sensitivity food that i was
tested was cow's milk which i kind of
had a sneaking suspicion because i
definitely do get some sort of reaction
with cow's milk but the one that really
surprised me was bananas like i had
never ever thought that bananas would
give me any sort of reaction but it
definitely showed up as a food
sensitivity with this test and it's
really cool because every well gives you
options of what to do with this
information like for example you can
give it to your physician to help guide
the next steps they actually suggested
for me to do a food elimination diet to
actually see if these foods that popped
up on my test actually gave me any sort
of reaction so everly will also has high
quality vitamins and supplements to
support your overall health you can
choose from a variety of options
including vitamin d3 and omega-3 fish
oil i personally am taking vitamin b12
and actually really liking it it's very
high quality ingredients here so here's
how it works beverly well ships products
straight to you with everything that you
need in one package to take your at-home
lab tests you simply collect your sample
and use the included prepaid shipping
label to mail back your tests to a
certified lab your physician reviewed
results get sent to your phone or device
in just days and you can share the
results with your primary care physician
to help guide next steps if you ordered
vitamins and supplements you can start
adding them to your daily routine right
away it's so simple over 1 million
people have trusted everly well to
support their health and wellness goals
and you should too for our listeners of
the show everywhere is offering a
special discount of 20 off and at home
lab test at
everlywell.com big mood that's
big everlywell.com for 20 off your next
at home lab test
everlywell.com
big mood you get a mixer
pineapple okay oh yeah i like pineapple
we never get to drink together
and i do have frozen breast milk i can
drink oh [ __ ] dope and it'll make it
oh i thought what
oh we were gonna make a pina colada yeah
i thought we were gonna
i meant i can drink yours and you're
gonna drink
that's what we all thought
what i'm able to consume alcohol and my
childhood
moved yeah my child would still be fed i
hated i accepted it so we were like oh
yeah
and drinking together and she's like
i've got frozen breast milk i'm able to
they're excited that i get to drink with
them she's over here like ew
oh cause you thought the same thing yeah
i was like what do you mean you're gonna
drink your frozen basketball
hilarious
i mean i drank it before you know she
really tears it down for you yeah yeah
completely different reactions
no because with me and casey that's
that's our that's our language every
time he's like oh i'm gonna order a beer
or whatever i'm like because we went to
a concert recently and i was like oh
yeah like you're away yeah uh luca has i
always almost call him isaac luca has
some frozen breast milk at home he's
with my mom he's taken care of i can
drink because then i can have one drink
and then wait two hours for the drink to
like get out of your system alcohol and
then i could start feeding him after two
hours without so you don't have to like
get rid of a cycle of breast milk with
one drink with one okay but if you drink
like two or three drinks you would have
to like then would you have to pump and
dump i i don't know i haven't looked
into it because i don't drink more than
one yeah anyway so yeah but anyway
that's hilarious so yeah that i was like
cool you guys are excited about me
getting to join you guys to drink
i was like
[ __ ] you i want the breast milk
i can give you my alcohol breast milk yo
alcohol infused breast popsicles
there's a market for this somewhere
she's so disgusted yeah yeah i mean the
thought of drinking breakfast or the ice
cream
blend you put it in the smoothie and
there have been stories in history where
um they were like people were going
through a famine or something and the
only way they survived was they gave
them the food to the uh the uh the woman
who's lactating and they would just
drink that milk to survive there's
another story it's a very famous
painting how many people is that going
to feed that's ridiculous no they're
like they're so much
all the nutrients you ever need to
survive off right but how many people is
that going to feed two
i don't know whatever your body yeah
whatever your body is like that's
amazing like at least eight people
survive off that it was a family there's
another there's a there's a very famous
painting also of a man in prison
back in like [ __ ] i don't know the
1700s or some [ __ ] or another and he's
sucking on the breasts of a woman who's
standing at visiting him at prison it
was his daughter because he was
sentenced to death and they didn't give
him anything to eat so you know how they
would search people to when they come
visit you she didn't have anything she's
had herself so she would like secretly
feed him her breast milk so sad he ended
up surviving for two months and then
they were like how the [ __ ] are you
surviving the court was basically like
what the [ __ ] all right fine you can go
and he they let him go because he
survived office what
was he there for
oh stealing he stole a thing of bread oh
okay yeah like he murdered a whole
civilization right
they were like you lived too long we'll
let you go you're good but yeah he just
told him how was he on death row and
then they let him go because times were
crazy back then i don't know crazy back
then people got bored people didn't live
longer than two months really so right
yeah exactly like that was amazing
like the life they're saying was like
five months of anointed you you can go
exactly i wouldn't i wouldn't be
surprised if that was what it was crazy
yeah so now if we ever like if we if we
die here or if we get locked in here
you're keeping this right from me that's
true i think jess would rather die i'd
rather die i don't know the thought of
it it's the only thing
about our life supposedly the one that
makes a pose
it makes me think of like puss i don't
know why
i know that it's not and it's
milk yeah i drink there's a lot of
there's a lot of pus in cow's milk just
fyi that's what actually got me off of
it
i don't know drink i was just kidding no
i'm not kidding like i used to get milk
lattes all the time and then i read
about all the pus that's in milk like
for real
in milk um and then i couldn't i only
could taste puffs after that yeah what
does this taste like
i haven't really had that much milk
lately too i switched to soy milk
because i've been making all these
matcha lattes too so i might be yeah
we have so many different types of milk
we have coconut almond soy and oat yeah
no calories that's all the ones you need
and breast milk yeah we have all the
best cheese
i think almond milk is bad for the
environments i don't know about that one
you don't need the pus-filled cow's milk
yeah but too much soy is not good for
you either yeah that has like fake
estrogen
it's too much estrogen it is true i
don't know it's one of the it's one of
the bad what was it seven foods you
could have it in moderation though but
like i don't i don't milk all i have is
in like a matcha log what about tofu
like soy yeah so
much tofu there was a story there i
remember i did a story for jk news where
there was this guy who had like an
insane amount of gallbladder stones
because all he ate was tofu well if all
you eat is one thing one thing yeah it
doesn't matter what it is no but it's
like if you don't even
have health problems too yeah it's
calcified his [ __ ] everybody's body's
different you should moderate everything
yeah like know one thing only
yeah you're supposed to avoid
cows cow products
soy
corn
what else gluten sugar
just don't eat yesterday yeah it was
something else what did i do
photosynthesis
you don't do that i don't do that
in your sleep
you're just only having mini strokes i
have never consumed water unless it's in
like a coffee or something yeah that's
true how am i alive
i i wonder that everything you'd be
releasing from death row for sure they'd
be like we can't kill her you know my
toenail popped off for no reason what
excuse me i don't remember that yeah and
that's why i tweeted that you're gonna
eat a vegetable please are you currently
using it no no this was the wall back
like last time a few months ago my pinky
nail just popped off i was like oh did
you have a fungus no
it just happens everything so the body
is just wait it just happens
it's not the first slime your toenail
just comes i swear to god it just pops
off and then like underneath there's
already another layer with trees like
when they don't have enough nutrients to
feed all the leaves that's when they
start dropping their leaves oh [ __ ]
you're dropping you're just dropping
your [ __ ] toenails off because
we don't have enough nutrients we can't
nutrients your whole body so you don't
you're losing assistant though gina
because you're so vain and you care
about your looks but you don't care
about your health i know it's a terrible
existence you're just trying to cover it
with plastic things yeah it's a
difficult existence it makes no sense
like my
job in my career my livelihood is the
way i look and i do nothing
to maintain other than your skincare we
all have a good 10 years yeah i'm asian
it's fine they'll die pretty yeah i'll
die pretty pretty
yeah so i've i've sometimes my pinky
toenails pops off but i honestly think
it's because like when i was in my early
20s i worked a convention and i wore
heels for like 12 hours for like four
days straight and not used to wearing
heels and i remember my my two ex like
pinky and then one next to it went numb
for like
i think like a year or so like what i
got am i feeling back numb for a year i
swear to god i go to a doctor no bro
jesus i had insurance back then you
could go to a doctor without insurance
you just get like 100 bucks or whatever
i didn't have insurance for a while so i
think that's the reason why sometimes my
pinky nail just pops off and then
another one's like right underneath so
you genetically altered your [ __ ]
toenails probably you're like a lizard
you just keep your
eyelashes but no [ __ ] toenails the
[ __ ] man like we gave you an extra
supply because
if your eyelashes fall off they don't
grow back they do
it's like in case you have to get away
and you're someone's got you by your
pinky toes
has that ever happened to you like
playing with the lizard or anything yeah
i was literally i played with one in the
apartment
close to them you guys oh yeah a lot of
lizards
all the time
every time i try to get near one it
always runs away it's probably better
for you you know somebody they know
because when i was a kid i had two pet
lizards and i accidentally killed them
they know i think they know they told
each other
wait these are i can't remember if it
was lizards or hamsters but i remember
much different creatures
no no i did have both as pets but the
ones that i killed i can't remember
which ones they were i think so hamsters
before i think it was hamsters huh
because i was cleaning out their cage
and i and then for some reason i thought
it was a good idea to put the container
over the animal
instead of like in the container and
then cover it or whatever i put it over
the animal and then i accidentally like
chopped it in half because i was trying
to you chopped the [ __ ] hamster in
half it was trying to run away i can't
remember if it was a lizard or a hamster
what was the [ __ ] container a
guillotine
i didn't chop it i squashed it i
squashed
it i know i meant to say well it was
like i severed their body with like
stuff
yeah i think it was like a
tupperware or something like i'm
traumatized i know me too you put your
whole body way into that slam i think i
did i was like eight years old i was
like eight or nine
okay i think so the lizards watched this
scene and they're like you saw what you
did before
i think so
i think so
[ __ ] hilarious this is an innocent
murder
manslaughter or cancer slaughter out of
all of us if somebody were to ask like
which one of you guys were more likely
to kill animals when you were kids i
would have never guessed tiff i would
have never said definitely would have
been jess yeah right yeah really why me
i don't know
or maybe gina gina's the one that's
that's true
but she's the one guessing her shirt
says go to hell like yeah it literally
does because that's where her lord is
yeah
try to see luca
yeah no and then i i i've said this
before is
my mom taught me
that to pluck the wings from ladybug so
they want to fly away ladybugs your mom
told you to pluck the wings from
ladybugs because they wouldn't fly away
no no no
play with them so they wouldn't fly away
and like i it wasn't wait but then
they're they're ugly yeah they're not
the red they're [ __ ] red things no no
no no
under the
i know how they look like i don't rip
them off but i know but i didn't know it
was a bad thing yeah of course i was a
child obviously you're just doing what
someone tells you yeah i didn't know i'm
horrified
i don't i've never done that
myself
but i did catch a lizard one time and i
tried to pet it like this yeah like the
opposite way it's back no like the
normal way like from head to tail yeah
pet the lizard that i caught and his
tail came off and [ __ ] traumatizing
oh [ __ ] he released his yeah the whole
[ __ ] tail came off and it was like we
used to find lizard tails all over the
place
my cat used to try to catch him and then
they would
i
wonder
release
their
taste like taste yeah
are you just trying to be provocative i
want to know i just thought i like you
really want to eat a lizard tail aren't
you not curious no not at all just a
little bit
you eat crazy [ __ ] all the time yeah but
i can't relate if they if it was a
cuisine and like it was something that
people already ate like it was right a
thing then i try it yeah like a gator
yeah i've tried that oh
i'll see giant lizards like dinosaur
prehistoric lizards but not [ __ ]
mcgee in your garden yeah yeah yeah
you're a lesser child if it's not an
establishment
thank you
if it's not an established cuisine food
thing that someone's already tried and
done it then i'm not trying to be
curious about it pretty sure sometimes
so someone else has to establish the
rule first so you're a follower i'm a
[ __ ] yeah follower
were they all lizard lizard tails you'd
be like all right i'll try it yeah yeah
she's already done it okay okay if she's
already prepared if she has a recipe and
it's already something that's been done
try to try it you just want to try it in
your recipe you like don't want to yeah
no experiments no no no no it has to be
an accepted thing that people like
eating some wild [ __ ]
party oh like
some [ __ ]
yeah we've actually eaten like canned
snakes
you never ate the balloon though that's
great no i did did you i thought you
didn't not the actual bird right i
couldn't do the birthday
that's the beautiful
that was the one thing i thought you
couldn't do it but the white side said
absolutely not well we never i never
even got it served to me like okay well
one of my grandparents wanted everyone
to be americanized so like we didn't do
a lot of like we had absolutely the
basic cultural thing the juice was
delicious juice is great the juice was
bombing i had that but i couldn't do the
bones like yeah i just couldn't do it
yeah i think the dog food was probably
the worst at jk party i haven't had i
should it was like a weird and almost
bitter tasting it was strange dogs are
weird yeah
that's probably out of all things i've
ever eaten that was probably the worst
thing i've ever eaten this dog food oh
[ __ ] yeah i i was i hate too many things
i don't even know i think i blocked it
from my mind like trauma like
i can't remember because of jkp i used
to take a a thing of um apple cider
vinegar every morning for health reasons
somehow when i [ __ ] cared i guess
careful like body's like survival pace
and then i remember we did that smoothie
challenge and there was uh apple cider
vinegar and smoothie
when it came out from that point on i
can't smell it anymore without wanting
to vomit yeah
yikes but now you eat weird [ __ ] on gg4
you guys have challenges but they're not
that extreme like you got prepared from
jk party yeah we haven't done anything
that crazy before and you have to eat
like some hot sauce or some [ __ ] i think
i had a grilled cheese with gushers in
it
it was awful those are just like yeah
when isaac was little he used to like
eating his grilled cheese with
strawberry syrup that's kind of cool
yeah i was like that's a cool invention
we came up with it yeah i thought it was
weird cheese and flavor go together yeah
that's true that makes sense but it was
like it was that yeah exactly it's a
white dress
there's grilled cheese yeah it's like a
poor man's a charcuterie yeah exactly or
like there's some sandwich that has like
raspberry something in it i forgot
it's a it's not that reuben is it a
reuben no it's like it's got a name the
cranberry and turkey one well there's
that too yeah it's very similar this
whole conversation derails like creating
no sense and i love it yeah i just
ordered liquor while we were talking so
the next episodes might be drunks you're
welcome you're welcome
thank you for watching
frozen breast milk in there yeah we'll
be here in austin y'all
yeah y'all ever hauled out of cucumber
being very very serious microwave it for
30 seconds it feels like the real thing
i learned it when i met my wife on
ancestry.com all right see y'all later
and please remember that we're very
serious people very serious we're only
serious no jokes leave nikki alone
go get some [ __ ] friends that you can
joke around with
a biggity [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
you